you are the number one most dreaded
person to get the name this year and
again it's not just the economics of it
it's the their doubting your smarts
coming from the staff that they came to
me and they say they'd given someone
about gift before but they just know
because they don't know right here last
year right and so they're worried that
the unknown with you is that it will
probably be a bad gift again because
some are worried that you're stupid
don't look at me when you say that no I
just I certainly didn't say stupid
however did imply stupid I I will use
the word simple be a simpleton no every
idea that hotdog has for a date is to
just go to the comedy club that's really
smart Travis is a great time that lacks
originality it lacks originality and it
shows that he's cheap because every date
that he goes on he texts Jim to true as
a matter of fact hot dog what did you do
on Saturday I got some cop tickets and I
saw Jim here is this is hot dog in his
purest form for those that don't know
hot dog he helps us out here at the show
but he also he works with me a lot he
was waiting outside Caroline's for his
date remember like last week I said that
Jim shows up to his gigs right before I
go on right before he goes out meaning
late like before after the show has
already started and the openers on and
everything that's when Jim shows up so
he can show up and just walk right on
stage I had a 7:30 show I was probably
740 when I walked into the building Jim
saw hot dog outside the building I'm
like what are you he waiting for the
show Dario
showed already started yeah what time
did you finally get in I wanted to make
sure I had my comp tickets what time did
you finally get in so you 20 minutes
late for the show 20 minutes you know I
live it I would have been at the person
yeah he was fine with it didn't you
think to come in and leave their name at
the door I didn't want to look
suspicious why suspicious you're not
smuggling you are supposed to be there
what suspicious you lagaye my friend is
late well
I was my friend was later then what I'm
not gonna go inside and then come back
out to get her you don't have to leave
her name in place she's my plus one
yeah I should have done that so is that
so I'd say I'm the side of people that
are you're not looking forward to
getting gifts from the vibe that I'm
picking up is hot dog up in Dennis
Falcone are the guys that you don't want
to have your name you don't know about
my Travis is very thoughtful I think
Troy is very thoughtful which I spent a
hundred bucks yeah so everybody should
we get started I think we should yes all
right shall we find out who should start
who should receive a gift first do you
think I don't um why don't we you know
what I wish we had a way to do it
randomly but we don't I mean we could
but let's just find out Denny who did
Dennis who did you get let's start with
one of the people that people are
dreading who did you get whose name did
you draw Mike Montone I learned from
last year and I remember last year it
was Anthony I had was no longer on the
show right and I gave him a gift card to
Applebee's what a specific gift card and
what was the value of the gift card $25
you know why you know why the to 420
meal smart bring a date right accent if
so this is official serious a satellite
radio letterhead it's a SiriusXM
envelope for my son talent chiles but it
appears to just be a one-year
subscription it's it's a membership to
the jelly of the Month Club
Mike Montone opening oh that's a nice
little gift card Danny put some
into the ants wrapped up I don't know
there's a gift cause you're right I'm
just assuming it
I mean it's thin like a gift card in it
it's a $25 gift card to Buffalo why
that's not bad that's a high-protein
meal Dennis you know that Mike is a
workout guy you know he stays in shape
you know he eats salads every day why
would you give chicken wings chicken but
it's like processed chicken so you could
get a chicken wrap you could get
something else there I mean yeah Mike
how often you go to be Debs
I'm gonna go now I didn't ask that you
don't go often I've never been one more
Jim and Sam catch up with full episodes
and interviews from celebrity guests
anytime on demand using the Sirius XM
app
[Music]